[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRIYANA DAVIS: We have lots
of sheets of paper.
We told them to think about
stuff that they're thinking
about, stuff they want
to know more about.
And so they all wrote it down
on pieces of paper and put
them up all around the room.
And then everyone got
super fun stickers.
And we'd like...anything that
you had a story related to, you would
put sticker on that sign.
NAIMAH HAKIM: This course is about
bringing together two
teams, the university team and
the youth ensemble, which is a
conglomeration of students from
various middle schools
and high schools.
TADESH INAGAKI: We're meeting up,
once a week, with a group of
awesome kids, from the Princeton
area, and working
with them to create a devised
theater piece.
SARAH PATON: The class has been amazing
we have a group of young people,
ages, like middle school age.
And they get to come
here every Friday.
And we are devising
a piece with them.
ERICA NAGEL: I'm Erica Nagel.
And I'm the Artistic Engagement
Manager at McCarter
Theatre Center.
And I also teach for the Lewis
Center at Princeton.
When we started the project, we
didn't know what the play
was going to be about.
We just knew we had a bunch
of enthusiastic people.
And together we came to
the topic of dreams.
ALLISA WAGNER: It seemed like a
perfect blend of theater and a
service initiative.
ERICA NAGEL: So our partner for
this course is Community
House, which is an on-campus
organization that runs after
school programs.
And a lot of Princeton students
tutor for them.
And we are their Fun Friday
activity for this semester.
So we have some kids from
Community House.
We also have some kids
just from the
broader Princeton community.
MAEVE BRADY: I think one of the
most exciting thing is while
they can be shy and a little
tentative in this new
environment, once they're really
comfortable, is how
uninhibited they can be and how
much fun they can have.
MIRIAM HOLMES: I hope that the youth
ensemble members feel
proud when they see their work
on stage but also feel proud
that they worked together to
make that happen and not just
by themselves.
MAYA: I'm having fun.
It's a great way to interact
with people at different ages.
And we're doing all these
different things,
improvisation, tableaux.
It's really fun.
NAIMAH HAKIM: I think one of the
best things about this course
is it's shown me how you don't
need some kind of Einstein,
aha moment to be able
to create a play.
It can just be a series of
little moments, working with
people that you know, working
with teachers.
And building upon those
moments can
create something awesome.
[MUSIC PLAYING]